okay good so let me start right to the
title of this talk is yes there's an
oblivious RAM lower bound which sounds
like there was a question and now you
get to the question later on to the talk
and this is John works with the yes but
boost Nilsson who is professor in office
University in the cryptic group so so
what's in the Bolivia's Ram so nobilis
Ram was introduced in 1996 by God right
in Ostrovsky and what is the idea the
idea is that you have some sort of you
have an algorithm the runs on a random
access machine and what you want to do
is you want to somehow encrypt the
memory access pattern of your algorithm
okay so let me try to motivate it a bit
so imagine that you want to run a
program under the computational device
with limited memory but you have this
like a latch server where you can put
your data but maybe you don't trust this
server so so what you could do is you
could try to you could encrypt the data
of course with the server by looking at
the data cannot learn what it is did
you're storing but maybe you will also
want to run some sort of algorithm on
your data while it's sitting at the
server for instance you could imagine
like let's say I have a graph that I'm
storing on my server and maybe I want to
run the breadth-first search in my graph
and even though so maybe I can just
encrypt every memory word at the server
but if the server looks at what I'm
doing the memory ecstasy's of my
breadth-first search algorithm you could
actually learn something about the graph
that i have as input right if you think
about what a breadth-first search does
it's quite obvious that you can deduce
something from the memory access pattern
so the idea is that you want to be able
to take any Ram algorithm and then
somehow transform it into another one
where the server cannot learn anything
by observing the access pattern okay so
here we don't really care about the
server looking at the contents of what
you're storing because you can always
handle that with like normal encryption
techniques so it's just the access
pattern that we want to office Kate
so so busy the setup is that you have
this server when you put the data or the
server and then there's someone a nice
trouble that looks at your access
pattern but not your actual data and the
requirement is that this eavesdrop is
not allowed to learn anything about your
input based on the access pattern okay
and more formally if you have two
sequences of accesses to your data of
the same length then the eavesdropper
cannot distinguish the two sequences yes
this is like a picture of the setup
so you'll CPU here is your client you
have a small memory available it's not
big enough to store all your data the
data that you want to store is you can
think of it as an array of n entries
this is the normal RAM of the program
you're simulating what you have to do is
you have to actually store it somewhere
at the server memory you might actually
use more memory over here than you dip
down there as there's no restriction
saying that you cannot blow up the
memory usage so you have an array you
want to represent it but you want to
support and this array is just write
operations and read operations okay and
the way you support them is that each
read or write will be translated into
some number of probes into the server
memory so you get chose probes just to
distinguish the read and write from what
is happening at the server and also
because we're going to use cell probe
techniques to prove lower bounds so this
this is the server memory it's divided
into cells the input is an array with
entries so cells is the actual
representation and entries is just the
input the array that you're representing
okay the CPU only has the client memory
here yeah and see and gets the
operations one at a time
but youths new store it like let's say
initially the array is all zeros and
then you process some sequence of reads
and writes and you do that by making
probes into the members of your
representing in here so this is
basically your data structure and this
is just your input that you're
representing and what the user oversees
is just this sequence of accesses right
so what are the addresses of the cells
that I probe at the server okay the goal
is that the eavesdropper cannot learn
anything about what are the reads and
writes that I'm performing so there's of
course there's a Neve solution to this
does anyone see the naive solution if I
have a Rand Mel with them how can I make
it up Livius yeah just carry everything
every single time right and so then you
don't learn nothing by observing the
excess pattern right but that's of
course a huge overhead tool in your
overhead as we want to do better than
than that and so here is like the main
performance metric that we care about
it's the bandwidth overhead which is
just how much extra do I have to read in
order to obfuscate the memory access
pattern so more technically if I have if
I'm simulating
n excesses to a random access memory and
I do that by making M probes at the
server then the bandwidth overhead is
the following so you go back to the
slide here so the input has our bits in
every cell and the server has W bits in
every cell so they don't need to be the
same in most natural cases they're the
same but there's some upper bounds that
have different parameters that only work
when they're not the same so here we
included them as separate parameters so
they basically like the minimum possible
number of bits that needs to be read if
I'm doing n X disease and each array
interests are bits n are and how many do
I actually read will I read MW bits okay
so the overhead is MW over in R is how
much extra I have to access in order to
obfuscate
what I'm doing okay so they have a bunch
of our bounds already in the original
paper they prove that you can actually
do you can do the pull logarithmic
overhead I think maybe a lot cubed N or
something like this
and there's a whole bunch of different
suggestions for these a ramps with
different parameters some have a very
large client memory and then they can
still perform well and but what they
seem to care the most about is when the
client memory is just like a constant
number of words the best sort of options
there recently was this path o RAM from
2013 where you can get an overhead of
login if the cells at the server have
login bits and the cells of the input
have locked Square and bits sort of
that's why I have the separate parameter
this doesn't work if they're both login
and then at this year's folks that's an
improvement that gets login back login
when the word sighs both settings are
login okay so the most natural sitting I
would say so it's almost down to login
of course you'd ask what about lower
bounds for this problem so in the
original paper where they introduced the
problem they proved a log in lower bound
so what is the model for the lower bound
I think it's a model that most of you
would not like in this audience so
basically it's they say that your
algorithms have balls and bins algorithm
ok so the only thing this server can do
when you want to start a memory cell you
just treat it as an atomic unit and put
it in some location so you could do
anything if you do is shuffle things
around you cannot really do like you
cannot sort of do X or tricks on
different things you cannot sort of a
plan error correcting code to the data
that you're storing and one could
imagine that stuff like that could help
to hide what you're doing right do some
sort of error correcting code err yeah
exactly so so they're low about only
holds if you do not do such things right
so you just have to move things around
in atomic units it also holds only if
you have to be secure against an
adversary with unbounded computation
time so it means it means that basically
maybe you can break this login barrier
by using some sort of crypto assumption
that factoring is hard and based on this
assumption you can do better
still that was still a possibility after
their lower bound one positive thing
about this lower bound is that it holds
a horse also for what is called an
offline Oh ramps which means that the
low bar holds even if the client knows
the entire sequence of operations that
it wants to perform ahead of time so you
can look at the entire thing and then
decide how am I going to perform my
ecstasy's to the memory okay so in that
sense it's a strong lower bound because
holes for these offline evidence as well
okay so that's sort of the state of
affairs and then you know thirty years
passed and nothing happened to this
lower bound until 2016 when someone has
is there really an oblivious RAM lower
bound right so this is the question that
we answered in our paper right so so
what they did here was that they
revisited this although about and
pointed out these you know caveats with
the lower bound the problems here and
and then they proved something that
should would suggest that it's going to
be very very difficult to strengthen the
previous lower bound so what this show
is that okay so assume there is a
sorting circuit a circuit that can saw
integers with W bits each and that
circuit has size little n W login you
can get in W login by running some sort
of like a merge sort or whatever right
so it so assume you can do better than
that then you can use that to get one of
these offline Oh ramps which breaks the
login barrier so what does it mean so it
means that if I somehow managed to
strengthen their lower bound so that it
still holds in the offline setting but
it also holds if you'll have to do bit
tricks then I would also prove a lower
bound of MW login on the circuits
complexity of soaring right and of
course we don't have any such lower we
don't even have anything beyond NW right
the size of the input
so you would get like a super linear
circuit lower bound if you could prove
if you could strengthen this low bound
to big tricks this way okay so it's not
saying that probably the low bonds false
that's not what it's saying it's just
saying that's probably going to be hard
to prove the low bond
well they suggested instead is what
about what if we drop this offline
restriction so what if we want to prove
low bounce only for online oh rims
what's an online over I mean online or M
is one where you do not know the
sequence of operations in a band but
they just arrive to you one at a time
now you have to do a read now we have to
do a write and anyways if you think
about applications this is always what
you need right if I want to run a
breadth-first search i don't know in
advance unless I know the entire graph I
don't know in advance what operations
I'm going to perform and the whole idea
was that the data was too big to start
locally so most applications this is
what I need anyways so you could try to
drop this offline assumption and that's
what we do so our work prove lower
bounds for arbitrary algorithms so
they're allowed to do all the bit tricks
you like just to any representation and
we also strings from this assumption
here so it's not it doesn't hold only
against unbounded computation time
adversaries it holds even if you just
require that no polynomial time
adversary can distinguish two sequences
quite interesting that we can prove
lower bounds against such you know you
know crypto assumptions will not help
you that's basically what we can prove
here
and of course then we drop the offline
sitting so now in the lower holds only
for online or rent you get so the set up
for now is just these reads and write
requests come one at a time and this is
what you need in applications anyways
and all the other bands also work in the
online setting
so just back this was just a setup again
now going to give you the ideas of the
proof the rape ropes the memory and the
client memory yes we take the same login
log on from before and prove it again
under these assumptions okay so let's
just look at the simplest case let's say
there's no client memory just to give
the idea of the proof and let's say it's
like we have this perfect obliviousness
again that even with unbound
compensation time you cannot distinguish
the two just to start out in an easy
setting and let's say the size of these
entries is the same just holds for any
RW no matter the trade-off between them
the lower bound under the assumption
that your RM is secure also against
someone who can has unbounded
computation time to distinguish these
two sequences you read you know that
you're trying to work
see DJ on the program is yeah I'm going
to say that even if this eavesdropper
here has that looks at the access
pattern if she has unbound computation
time I'm assuming that even if she has a
manhunt in time she cannot distinguish
them you know it's better if I can prove
it when she is alone on even if she just
as polynomial time so the lower bound
soul so what I'm saying is if so so I'm
going to define like a hot sequence of
operations and then we're going to
analyze it
so the have sequencer here's one signal
of a race I'm not going to claim this is
the hard one but what am I doing here so
I this is some think of this as time
left right and then in the beginning I'm
just going to in the first array entry
I'm going to write some piece of data R
1 I 1 is just going to be add random
bits and then I'm going to write to the
second into the third entry and so on
and I'm going to do that in half times
and then I'm just going to read them off
again one by one so then you can ask the
following questions so look at this
sequence of operations and split them
into two halves the first half in the
second half then I'm going to ask so
when I process this sequence of read
operations over here how many cells
would I need to read that were written
in this part questions so I'm counting
how many times will I have to access
something that was written over there
does anyone see how what do you think in
this case
yeah at least I know what to write it's
just too much entropy in something to
know there's too many bits here you just
you need to read something that can tell
you what those bits are there's eight of
them you have to read eight cells just
to transfer the bits okay so what does
this technique come from where you sort
of look at two consecutive intervals and
count the number of probes that are
happening so this is taken from one of
these old data structure lower bound
papers by me hi Pat rascal and Erik
Demaine I think maybe it was even in the
house first paper where they prove log
in the lower bounds for dynamic data
structures so what we're going to do is
we try to use the technique but of
course this technique will not do the
trigger long because basic what we're
looking at is an array problem write
read and write and an array problem has
a very efficient solution if you're not
required to be oblivious all right so
this technique you know so if you're not
trying to exploit the obliviousness then
we're not going to get a login lower
bound so we need to do something more
and the trick here is this and now let's
change to this dummy sequence of
operations this is another sequence and
before it just you know every single
aberration the first half is just right
to entry serial just right they all
zeros bit string and you just do that in
half times and then you just read entry
0 and a half times so now the question
is for this read sequence of raising
this dummy sequence
how many probes will they have to be
between the first half and the last half
hey it has to be eight right because
otherwise the East Road can distinguish
the two sequences right so the East
robber because she sees the access panel
so she can just count how many times
it's the second half accessing something
that was written in the first half so
she just looks at this exes sequence and
checks you know what's there eight
Propst or not and if you probe less than
eight things over here she could
distinguish the two sequences so for
this dummy sequence there will also have
to be eight probes that are made by the
second half of the reads into what was
written during the first half before
these writes makes sense so far and now
we're going to do a new high and Eric
did we're going to look at different
sizes of these intervals but this time
now I'm going to look at a different
distribution over sequences right so now
I'm going to do for rights for reads for
rights for reads and now I can now look
at the first half you look at how many
times will these reads have to access
something that was last written over
here expect the argument as before you
have to access for things because
there's just so many bits you need to
transfer and now you do the second you
do the same here because this was after
everything that was done here accessing
stuff that came before there was access
before it doesn't help you because
there's just not enough there's no
information and everything was done up
to here to help you answer these read
operations so therefore there has to be
a lot of operations in this sub interval
that access something that was last
written and that's up in spoon and now
here's the trick because now we go back
to the same dummy sequence and this is
using the obliviousness you're not
allowed to distinguish the two so for
the dummy sequence the same thing has to
hold the operations in this half here
even though these are all reads there's
no information there but to hide the
access pattern you have to still access
something over there
otherwise you could distinguish yourself
from the previous sequence
and the observation which is also in
this original paper by me hi and Eric is
that all these probes that you count in
this way are all distinct because any
single probe that your algorithm does
will only it something to belong to one
of these sets right there is some sort
of unique last time the cell was
accessed and you're going to be put be
counted at the lowest common ancestor of
those two rows so what you can do is for
this red sequence if I want to know how
many probes are there in total I just
sum up all the probes in all these notes
so I can do another layer now I have
even smaller intervals and I can get
these two two two two two you see as I
get this very nice binary tree and all
that's left now is just to sum up
everything the tree read basically I'm
hiding that I'm not that I I want to
make sure that you cannot distinguish
the red sequence from this one I have to
still do I still here I have just by
here there's no obliviousness I'm just
saying there's just so much information
that I have to access a lot to get to
recover the information and here I'm
saying but I have to be
indistinguishable from that one so I
also have to do the same thing here
and I guess you see where the lower
bound is right the sequins head lengths
in this in half here they stop - in half
at this level is some - in half at this
level and in half year the highest login
so you get an end login lower bound on
the total number of ecstasy's okay which
means that the overhead is login and if
you want to consider different
parameters on w that are not the same
and you just realized that at every
level you had to recover all the bits
that's in our bits that requires in our
W probes and if you look at the overhead
it turns out that they cancel out and
it's still a login overhead okay then
there was this client memory because we
assumed there was no memory the clan
memory is easy to deal with just an
intuitive level so let's say the client
memory can hold - as room for two
elements in in some sense you can just
transfer you can keep two of the things
in memory when you go from the 1/2 of
intervals to the other half - to the
next interval because we can prove this
formally but I think the intuition makes
sense right the client memory cannot
hold more than two items so most of the
stuff you still have to do probes to
recover yeah just ignore the bottom log
and +1 levels everything above it has at
least half of the way it had before so
it's in over 4 per level at least and
it's amazing now if you sum everything
up its you basically get this lower
bound and it's just a log in over m
lower bound so the actually shows that
even if you allow very large client
memory up to n to the 1 minus epsilon
you still get a log in lower bound
okay and just give you the last I just
have a few minutes left the last case is
what if you want now you have this
computation indistinguishability like
you have against a polynomial time
adversary I guess if you think about it
what the what the East Java was doing
was just it was a long way back was just
counting these probes and these
intervals right she was just counting
and that's something she can do in
polynomial time he just counts so
already she's doing it in in the
trinomial time what you can say is what
if she's allowed to what if she what if
you only required that she's not allowed
to distinguish them with probability one
over four or something this is some
slack there and he's the same type of
proof go through so you can start by
proving a lower bound saying under this
random distribution that it's very
likely that you have to prove prove a
linear number of things like so with
probability 1/2 you have to read K or
four things if the interval has length K
something like this makes sense right
make sense that you almost always have
to read everything you can prove this
like with an encoding argument and that
means that the expected number of probes
under the read sequence also has to be
Omega K this follows just by Marcos
inequality right because if it was less
then the probability of seeing K over
fours no more than 1/4 which means you
can just check what's the more than K or
4 in the first sequence the blue
sequence this happened with probability
at least 1/2 and if this was not true it
would haven't be permitted most 1/4 so
that this there's this quarter gap that
you can use to distinguish the two
sequences with probability at least 1/4
and then you know now it's just expected
number of probes and fortunately use
linearity of expectation just sum it all
up and you know and then again we just
have to solve everything that's above a
certain level to deal with the memory
that's actually the foolproof yeah so
the lower bound is log in over m and
even if you just wanted to hold against
these for normal time bounded
adversaries also you know we extend the
proof to hold also if you're allowed
randomization so whenever you you answer
read you allowed to fail with some
constant probability the lower bound
still holds even in this case so base
there's nothing you can you can really
do to break the lower bound okay so this
is just like a summary of everything
that was has been done so there were
these previous upper bounds here's a
little bit more detail if you had word
size they had this path over m that had
an optimal overhead of log in but only
for sort of strange parameters but it is
tight according to our lower bound
because the lower hold for all
friendless and w if you want to both of
them to be log in they didn't quite get
there
there was this panel Rama from this just
[ __ ] that gets login law plugin and a
and and now we prove that the lower
bound has to be there's a log in lower
bound there's still a tiny gap but
actually after our work there was
something published on I think the print
that you can actually get the optimum
you can get a log in overhead with word
sighs both durian are being login okay
so suddenly in the last two years there
was this paper the question the
optimality and then suddenly everything
got solved not inspired by our proof for
this distance yeah by the fortunate
thing after 30 years everything happens
in if you
that's sort of the state here there's
one open problem that I think is
interesting here is something what if
you just want to store your data so that
sort of like a read-only data you don't
want to change the data that you're
storing at this server so maybe in some
sort of pre-processing phase you know
all the data now you're going to ship it
to the server and then later on you can
query it but you cannot you know you
have no right operation or have read
operations this tower bound is still
login but can you can you prove this is
a lower bound that you if you don't just
it reads only there's a log in the lower
bound you can easily fairly easily prove
it if you require that you're not
allowed to change what's stored at the
server while doing your read operations
then you can prove the long run but
actually here you have the problem is if
you have a client memory that may change
between operations and you can also sort
of modify what started the server maybe
try to move some things around you're
just not doing write operations we can
still modify the representation to hide
your access parent this is an
interesting
I don't know I don't think from listed
counting I don't know I am not sure what
can you do in it I'm not a good
complexity expert what can you do in I
guess you just need to count within a
constant factor that's enough for you
here I suppose I guess you just need I
guess in the reduction you should just
have to distinguish in one case we know
there has to be a linear number exercise
just has to distinguish that from a
constant factor smaller so you started
with the sibling select show me the
right you make that whether there is a
sequence of so the point of this fixed
read sequence is that we can the problem
is that for any fixed distribution over
these reads and writes if I have some
distributional reads and writes there's
like the blue distribution right this we
don't use the obliviousness yet so it's
just a data structure and there you can
do a linear time just read and write but
what you're doing right so the but we
use the red one for is in some sense to
collect all these different likely to
twelve something we can change the
underlying distribution to log in
different distributions that all of them
must have probes in different locations
and then we can have this one fixed one
that should do the same as all these log
and different ones I think that that's
the role of this this red sequences that
can somehow look at many different blue
distributions then I yield probes in
different
timespans in some sense and and then you
know we have to be indistinguishable
from all of them so you have to do all
the work that all these blue things did
in order to that sort of the role
there's this one fixed sequence that's
you have to hide against all the other
ones in there so you can collect all the
lower bounds yeah but you you don't know
the sequence of reads in advance so you
still have to still has to work even if
you don't know the sequence of meets an
event and they write to you an online
setting this sequence there in the in in
the offline setting you know the entire
sequence of reads yeah you know
everything you're going to do and then
you can you know decide something based
on the whole sequence you know I know
I'm I know that the first I'm going to
read number seventeen then I'm going to
read number three then I'm going to be
there's something in that line but it's
only four strains parameters that they
get something it's only like the word
size has to be locked cube ten or
something weird it's not quite the same
bit Faris I think yeah I think there's
something you can do if you don't look
at the bend with the overhead I think
that solution has a small bandwidth
overhead but you make many probes it's
something with having this w and I be
quite different as far as I remember
like we'd put a little bit make it
different it's faster limit so there's
still room to and I prove that we have
to do log and ecstasy's maybe not the
bandwidth overhead beam login but maybe
login ecstasy's would make sense
it look like you're dividing by a W in
your eye
yes which says lock squared and eyes
logon yeah yeah but it's still the best
you could hope to do would be some
constant on average right the amortize
could be less could be improved a
constant in this so yeah intuitively
yeah their overhead could be made even
smaller yeah right so the minimum is
this like so so what are we saying so we
do the best you can hope for right it's
in our over W if W / this is sub linear
so amortize could be sub linear and it's
still low - this has to be a log in fact
a bigger than this right so in some
sense it's still strong you can still it
still cannot do the best you could hope
for
no no if you plug them in no their
overhead is computed in this one the oil
is computed as this a using this formula
in W yeah
okay those
[Applause]